to defend the government's record in
what is probably going to be a live
recession with Kirsten I imagine going
full in on issues of the economy she
hasn't been helped this morning by the
former Chancellor former Health
secretary Javed who's been speaking at
an event and being quite critical of the
government saying the markets are in
turmoil because the tax cuts went far
beyond what Liz trust set out in the
summer when she was pitching uh to be
leader and he said they also spending
much more on the energy bailout and as
such a javid's view is they have to
convince the markets that the books will
be balanced in five years okay Beth
we're going to pause there take a quick
break join us in three minutes for prime
minister's questions
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS let's take you live now to the House
of Commons where prime minister's
questions is due to start any moment
let's bring in our political editor Beth
Rigby who is here Beth we slightly cut
you off from your crime just before the
break but it is a real Mammoth task for
the prime minister to start to turn
things around isn't it at the moment it
really is and those divisions about this
mini budget and the Fallout of it going
right through the back benches up to her
cabinet and there's questions about
whether or not more tax cuts will need
to be reversed or whether or not there
have to be big spending cuts The
Institute of fiscal studies talking
about a 60 billion uh pound whole in
times of spending yesterday and I have
to say the mood is very bad on the back
bench it's a former cabinet minister
saying to me this week that they thought
that it just wasn't sustainable that she
had messed up the party messed up the
country and messed up the prospects of
the party at the next election that they
do not think it's sustainable what
follows from that is unclear but it
should is the pressure she is under
she's on her feet it's the first
anniversary of the senseless murder of
our friends to David Amos
David was a superb parliamentarian who
brought colleagues across this house
together on a huge range of issues
he represented the best of parliament as
a debated champion of his constituency
our thoughts are with his wife Julia and
his five children as well as the people
of South End which now stands tall as a
city in Testament to David's tireless
work
Mr Speaker this morning I had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
and in addition to my duties in this
house I shall have further such meetings
later today
I knew uh sir David and I share the
prime minister's sentiments completely
uh spooking the markets and increasing
the cost of borrowing increasing the
cost of mortgages uh was almost
certainly an act of growth in competence
rather than malevolence
but going back on the commitment to end
no fault evictions is an act of extreme
calories
can the Prime Minister reassure the 11
million private renters in this country
that she will carry out the commitment
to get rid of no fault elections
I can
Julian sturdy
[Applause]
thank you Mr thank you Mr Speaker on a
recent visit to the children's Ward at
York Hospital I was shocked to learn
that pediatric waiting time targets are
the same as that of adult patients so as
we know any delay to treatment for young
patients can have a damaging effect on
development and their future prospects
so can I ask the prime minister to look
at this as a matter of urgency
well I'm very very sorry to hear about
the situation for young people at York
hospital and I'm pleased to say that
this is an issue that my right honorable
friend the health secretary is focused
on in her plan for patients we are
making sure that people can access
treatment as soon as possible we're
delivering record Staffing numbers and
putting in place record levels of
funding comes the leader of the
opposition
uh thank you Mr Speaker can I join with
the Prime Minister and her comments
about Sir David she spoke for the whole
house when she made those comments and I
know how deeply his loss was felt on the
opposite benches and we extend our best
wishes across at this important time
Mr Speaker I also want to send my
heartfelt condolences to the families of
all those who tragically lost their
lives in Chrysler last week
on a goal is a special place to me and
my family and across this house the
people there are in all of our thoughts
Mr Speaker this this morning the
bitter he toured the TV studios arguing
that the turmoil in the markets has
nothing to do with her budget
does the Prime Minister agree with him
well Mr Speaker what we have done is we
have taken to a site of action we have
taken decisive action to make sure that
people are not facing energy bills of
six thousand pounds
if we remember the opposition is only
talking about six months we've also
taken decisive action to make sure that
we are not facing the highest taxes for
70 years in the face of a global
economic slowdown and what we're making
sure is that we protect our economy
there's very difficult time
internationally and as a result as a
result of our action Mr Speaker and this
has been independently corroborated we
will see higher growth and lower
inflation
Mr Speaker avoiding the question ducking
responsibility lost in denial no wonder
investors have no confidence in her
government and this is why it matters a
few weeks ago Zach and Rebecca from
Wolverhampton were all set to buy their
first home then the government's
borrowing spree sent interest rates
spiraling and their mortgage offer was
withdrawn
I met them last week they're back to
square one unable to buy devastated sick
to the back teeth with excuses and blame
shifting just the primers to understand
why Zach and Rebecca are completely
furious with her
Mr Speaker
the fact is that when
facing energy bills of up to six
thousand pounds
[Applause]
party opposite are shouting but he is
opposing the very package that we
brought in the energy price guarantee
that was the major part of the mini
budget that we announced and Mr Speaker
he has refused to confirm whether or not
he backs our energy price guaranteed for
two years which protects families not
just this winter but next winter what
we're seeing Mr Speaker is we are seeing
interest rates Rising globally we are
doing the they are rising globally in
the face of Putin's appalling war in
Ukraine and what we are doing is helping
people with lower stamp Duty helping
people with their energy costs reducing
inflation with our energy package and
keeping taxes low and I notice that the
honorable gentleman had a Damascus
conversion last night when he backed our
cut to National Insurance
Mr Speaker The Economist in turmoil
people are really worried this is really
not the time to descend into absolutely
nonsense attacks about last night
there's no point there's no point
there's no point trying to hide it
everyone can see what has happened the
tourists went on a borrowing spree
sending mortgage rates through the roof
they are skyrocketing by 500 pounds a
month and for nearly 2 million
homeowners their fixed rate deals are
coming to an end next year they're
worried sick and everybody in this house
knows it they won't forgive they won't
forget and nor should they when will she
stop ducking responsibility do the right
thing and reverse her Kamikaze budget
which is causing so much pain
[Applause]
Mr Speaker last night the labor party
but he supported
National Insurance and is he really
is he really
I want to the Prime Minister I'm sorry
if the wrong party doesn't but I
certainly agree
Mr Speaker I'm genuinely unclear about
what label
I think we don't want an early bath at
this stage Rugby World Cups coming don't
start it too soon just let's hear the
questions and certainly the answer is
prime minister Mr Speaker I'm genuinely
unclear as so what
as to what the labor party's policy is
on our energy price guarantee it was the
biggest part it was the biggest part of
our mini budget are the oppositions
saying they want to revert it and they
want to see people facing energy bills
of six thousand pounds is that what he's
saying
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the the premise knows very
well that on this side we voted against
the National Insurance in the first
place
she she voted for it so who's paying the
u-turn
honestly last week the Prime Minister
was forced to u-turn on her unfunded tax
cut for the super wealthy this week
she's beginning to realize that she
needs to extend the windfall tax one
step behind the CEO of shell but she's
she's still going ahead with 18 billion
pounds of tax cuts for the richest
businesses and they didn't even ask for
it she's still gift wrapped a stamp Duty
cup for landlords just as renters feel
the pinch and she's still holding out
tax cuts for those who live off stocks
and shares why does she expect working
people to pick up the bill for her
unfunded tax cuts for those at the top
I noticed that the leader of the
opposition is still not saying whether
or not he supports our energy price
guarantee
it's very relevant Mr Speaker because it
is the biggest part
it is the biggest part of our mini
budget it's the biggest part of the mini
budget the fact is that all the
opposition have said is that people
should be supported for six months does
he think that in March pensioners should
be facing very high energy bills because
that's what will happen if he doesn't
support our energy price guarantee
Mr Speaker not even attempting to answer
the questions now I gently remind her
that the idea of freezing energy bills
was a labor idea that she then took on
during her leadership contest the Prime
Minister said and I quote her exactly
I'm very clear I'm not planning public
spending reductions is she going to
stick to that
absolutely absolutely
what we are look Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker we are spending
we are spending almost a trillion pounds
of public spending we were spending 700
billion back in 2010. what we will make
sure is that over the medium term the
debt is falling but we will do that not
by cutting public spending but by making
sure we spend public money well and the
honorable gentleman talks about our
spending which he doesn't seem to
support on the energy price guarantee
but the reality is he can't criticize us
on one hand for spending money on the
other hand claiming we're cutting public
expenditure
they can cheer I hope they listen very
very carefully to that last answer
because other people have listened very
very carefully to it
who voted uh
who voted for this
who voted for this who voted for this
not homeowners paying an extra 500 extra
on their mortgages who voted this not
working people paying for tax cuts to
the largest companies who voted for this
not even most of the MPS behind her who
know who know you can't pay for tax cuts
on the never never does she think does
she think the public will ever forgive
the conservative party if they keep on
defending this madness and go ahead with
our Kamikaze budget
Mr Speaker what our budget has delivered
is security
[Applause]
made sure that we're going to see higher
economic growth lower inflation and more
opportunities the way that we will get
our country growing is through more jobs
more growth more opportunities not
through higher taxes higher spending and
his friends in the union stopping
hard-working people get to work
Turtle burning come on show thank you Mr
Speaker I want to see growth and jobs in
East Cornwall and I believe an
investment Zone could help this would
the Prime Minister Back The Honorable
member for North Cornwall and myself who
are supporting a zone for Liskeard and
bobman area
more homes for local people in Cornwall
and I know that's what my honorable
friend is working towards with her
colleagues and I'm delighted we're
bringing forward these investment zones
that are going to give those
opportunities to local people hello
comes the leader of the SMP Ian
Blackfoot
thank you Mr Speaker and can I associate
myself with the remarks of the Prime
Minister on the murder of David Amos a
year ago and thoughts and prayers very
much with Julia and and his family and
of course uh we thank very much of those
in crestfather that have been caught up
in the incredible tragedy there as well
I would have hoped that if the prime
minister is making public spending
commitments today that she would have
said that those that rely on Social
Security benefits will get the benefits
operated in life
Mr Speaker when the Prime Minister last
stood at the dispatch box the average
two-year fixed rate mortgage stood at
four and a half percent
they're now at six and a half percent
and Rising hitting average families with
an extra
450 pounds a month of mortgage payments
every single month over and above what
they were paying 37 days into the job
this is literally the cost of the prime
minister's incompetence it is the price
households are paying and all because of
the chancellor that she chose exactly
well she now give up her desperate plan
to save her chance of her skin by
scapegoating the governor of the bank of
England
it
Mr Speaker the action we have taken has
meant that families in Scotland and
across the United Kingdom are not facing
gargantuan energy bills and what the
honorable gentleman and his friends in
Scotland could do to help us out is
build the nuclear power stations
get more gas out to the North Sea to
help deliver on a more secure Energy
Future for all of our people
up Mr Speaker that she wants you to ask
us questions we can swap places
the reality is Mr Speaker that the prime
minister is ignoring the damage of the
chaos of the mini budget she's worrying
about saving the Chancellor's job but
many families are now worried not just
about hitting their homes but keeping
their home for five minutes left the
scale of this Tory crisis is frightening
100
000 households a month are up for
mortgage renewals people can't afford to
pay an extra four and a half thousand
pounds a year in interest and plenty are
already falling behind the Prime
Minister and her Chancellor have
completely lost control the only thing
growing under this government are
mortgages rents and bills is that what
she really meant when she declared
herself a pro-growth prime minister
well we have taken action on helping
families Heat their homes and that's
been very important and I would love to
see more support on delivering the
energy security we need interest rates
arising globally that is a fact and
interest rates are a decision for the
Independent Bank of England but I want
do all I can to help families across
Britain but the way we're going to help
them is by delivering economic growth by
making sure we have the jobs and
opportunities in Scotland and right
across the UK and what independent
forecasters have shown is that following
our intervention economic growth is
going to be higher than it would have
been if we hadn't acted and that is
vitally important for the jobs the
opportunities and the livelihoods and
helping make sure people are able to put
food on the table
should Son thank you Mr Speaker
the way navigation winds through the
heart of Guilford and is a much
treasured part of our local environment
I welcome the announcement by the deafra
secretary last week that the
environmental agency will be able to
increase fines on water companies for
serious breaches of the rules to up to
250 million pounds per breach will my
right honorable friend confirm that no
MP voted to discharge sewage into our
waterways and that it is beneath the
opposition parties and their activists
to keep repeating this outright life
well well my honorable friend is
absolutely right about our support for
cleaner water and what we're doing about
it which The Honorable lady has asked
from a sedentary position is we have
increased and my honorable right
honorable friend the Deborah secretary
has increased the fines for water
companies a hundred times if they
discharge sewage in towards Works in
under the legal way we've acted
Sir Jeffrey Donaldson thank you Mr
Speaker can I associate my colleagues
and I with the remarks made about the
tragic events in Krishna in County
Donegal and our prayers continue to be
with that devastated Community does the
Prime Minister agree with me uh in
welcoming the renewed negotiations with
the European Union about the northern
protocol
that the outcome of those negotiations
must reflect the objectives outlined by
the government and the Northern Ireland
protocol Bill and that this is the key
to unlocking the door to political
stability in Northern Ireland
well I very much agree with the
honorable gentleman we need to deliver
for the people of Northern Ireland that
means making sure that we have
free-flowing trade East-West as well as
north-south it means making sure that
the people of Northern Ireland can
benefit from the same tax benefits as
people in Great Britain and it means
resolving the issues over governance and
regulation now I would prefer to achieve
that through a negotiated solution with
the EU but if we're not able to do that
we can't allow the situation to drift we
have to proceed with the Northern
Ireland protocol Bill Murray Robinson
thank you Mr Speaker addressing Health
inequalities is a key part of leveling
up and so I welcome this week's news of
50 million pounds to fund Research into
Health disparities we know poor health
affects not only life expectancy but
also prosperity and more widely economic
resilience and growth therefore would my
right honorable friend consider a future
expansion of these six schemes to other
parts of the North and the greater
Manchester region to encourage more
Health Care research Partnerships
between our great universities and our
local authorities
well my my honorable friend is
absolutely right that this health
research is vitally important I know
that my writing real friend the health
secretary is looking at whether and
where the scheme can be expanded and we
will be doing further commissioning
rounds to look at that issue John
McNally
thank you Mr Speaker prime minister you
have had a holiday check I think in
Birmingham picked into the choir
although the few MPS and appear to be
singing that were there appeared to be
singing from a different song sheet and
he Minister your government is now
outrageously Flirting With Disaster
financially and socially I was just here
the increase in mortgage repayments will
dwarf the rise in hitting bills how will
the government how will you cope with
the resultant increase in homelessness
I'm responsible as you but I'm sure the
Prime Minister will take that on board
well Mr Speaker
to deal with the very severe energy
crisis we are facing we are facing a
severe energy crisis we're also
inflating a Slowdown in economic growth
globally due to Putin's war in Ukraine
and not acting is not an option
[Music]
[Applause]
prime minister the energy price
guarantee is a key part of the growth
plan but too few businesses and
households know about it even if the
labor party don't support it can I urge
you to have a nationwide mail out
campaign to communicate what the
government is doing to assess people on
reduction or energy and more
particularly I have a reduction of
energy campaign by the public service so
that we don't go down the route of
spending too much on consumption we
reduce Supply
well my my um my right audible friend is
absolutely right and I know the energy
secretary is working on a plan to help
companies and individuals use energy
more efficiently we're also working on
this across government I was delighted
to speak to my friend yesterday and I
hope we'll be able to start this going
in number 10 straight away
thank you Mr Speaker Journal lockdown we
clap them and then we let reach for
healthcare staff who had died on the
front line and how quickly our nurses
have gone from the country's Heroes to
this government's villains offered a
derisory 72 pencil week peer rise and
then pre-ended as militants for daring
having the audacity for bulletin for
industrial action for the first time in
a century prime minister clubs don't pay
the bills and neither does 72 Pence peer
rise nurses are leaving the NHS and the
droves feeling abandoned by this
government surely surely even the Prime
Minister agrees that the government has
its priorities wrong
when Uncharted abortices of the fungus
and at the same time offering the rise
repair Rises to our treasured and India
chess stuff
well first of all could I say what a
brilliant job are fantastic nurses do
okay the figures he he's figure simply
wrong the independent pay review body
recommended a 40 1400 pound rise on
average and that is what the
government's committed to delivering
yeah that's in the outfit
following the loss of 27 lives last
winter in the channel the UK government
offered joint patrols to the French on
the beaches could my right arm around
the foreign minister confirm that you
renewed this offer to president macron
when they met and further that there'll
be no new money no fresh agreement with
the French unless they agree to Joint
Beach patrols and a joint security
Crossing across the channel to bring an
end to the small boats crisis for good
well the the Home Secretary is committed
to dealing with this very very difficult
issue of the small boats in the channel
we do need to sort it out we're
committed to legislating and we're also
committed to getting an agreement with
the French government I did discuss it
with President macron last week and the
Home Secretary is following up
[Music]
[Applause]
are hosting our community drop-in event
on the course of living crisis in global
this will be a chance for local
residents to come and meet with our
Ranger Partners to get advice and and
guidance and what they can do to help
survive the the current crisis could I
extend an invite to the prime minister
to come to this event on Friday so that
my constitutes could ask her directly
for real life experience means to
address the coast Rises that they are
facing and so that she can apologize to
them for the disastrous decisions our
government are making
well I completely understand that
families are struggling and that is why
this government acted within a week of
coming into office to put in place the
energy price guarantee so people aren't
facing six thousand pound fills and
that's why we reverse the increase in
National Insurance that's why we're
cutting basic rate tax to make sure
families are keeping more of their own
money and we're also making sure that
the most vulnerable households get an
extra 1200 pounds of support I hope he
is going to communicate that to his
constituency
thank you Mr Speaker can I first thank
the Prime Minister for warm words on to
David Amos who is sorely missed in this
place
smaller media size Enterprises are the
lifeblood of our economy and I warmly
welcome the expansion of the small
business threshold
does my uncle friend agree that the only
the only the conservative party is on
the side of Enterprise and their
determination to unleash the full
potential of our great country
[Music]
[Applause]
well we understand in the conservative
party who pays our wages and it's the
people who get up every day and go to
work it's the businesses who set up
those are the people driving our economy
and we will be unashamedly pro-growth
pro-business and pro-opportunity
see Cooper
thank you Mr Speaker my constituents
were absolutely delighted that the
fracking application in West Lancashire
was withdrawn after a moratorium was
declared since then we've not seen any
new scientific evidence that indicates
fracking would now be safe so despite
this the government decided to reverse
that moratorium committing to Grant
fracking licenses only in areas that
have local consent so I would be
grateful if the Prime Minister would
reassure West Lancashire residents my
constituents and please explain in
detail how she will honor her statement
the fracking licenses none of them will
be forced on communities that don't want
it
well first of all can I offer my best
wishes to The Honorable lady on her
appointment as the chair of the mersey
Care NHS Trust
I can absolutely assure her and
colleagues around the house that
fracking will only go ahead in areas
where there is local community support
thank you Mr Speaker two weeks ago a
bomb in Afghanistan killed 35 girls and
young women they were hussaros from the
country's second largest ethnic minority
who are being massacred onto the Taliban
today outside Parliament hazarus from
across the UK including from my
constituency are gathering calling for
international support to stop the
slaughter and we're joined here today by
representatives of the Hazara Council of
Great Britain will my right honorable
friend the Prime Minister support the
Hazara in trying to stop the killings
and arrange for her ministers to meet
their representatives
well it is extremely concerning what is
taking place in Afghanistan and I'm
afraid the reversal of women's rights
and women's opportunities and one of the
things we have done is make sure we're
restoring the aid budget for women and
girls and I'm sure my friend the right
or my friend the foreign secretary be
very happy to meet the group and discuss
further Daisy Cooper thank you Mr
Speaker the government's botched budget
gave unfunded tax cuts to some of the
richest companies whilst across the
country there are hospitals who worry
that their roofs might collapse at any
moment Hitchin Brook Hospital frimley
Park hospital and Queen Elizabeth
Hospital the prime minister's own local
area these are just three of a number of
hospitals who need together need
hundreds of millions of pounds some of
them
urgently so will the Prime Minister
promise that every affected hospital
will be given the money they need to fix
these dangerous roofs in the next 12
months yeah well I I do want to correct
The Honorable lady because what we are
doing is simply not putting up
corporation tax it's not a tax cut we're
just not raising corporation tax and I
feel it would be wrong in a time when we
are trying to attract investment into
our country at a time of global economic
slowdown to be raising taxes because it
will bring less Revenue in and the way
that we are going to get the money to
fund our National Health Service the way
that we're going to get money to fund
our schools is by having a strong
economy with companies investing and
creating jobs
[Music]
and I fully support this government's
growth agenda prime minister would she
agree with me that this can be achieved
whilst also protecting and restoring our
precious nature and ecosystems and
working with our Farmers so that we do
meet our legally binding Target to
restore Nature by 2030 I know she
understands this she has precious talk
screens in her own constituency and will
she agree that if we get this right
there will be more jobs skills
opportunities because every nation in
the world depends on its natural
environment
well my my honorable friend did a
fantastic job promoting the natural
environment when she was at defra
we are going to deliver
growth in an environmentally friendly
way what this is about is about
improving the processes and deliver
better outcomes both for the environment
whilst making sure we have a growing
economy as well and those two things go
hand in hand mothers
thank you Mr Speaker the Prime Minister
wants us to believe that fracking will
reduce our energy bills but it was not
so long ago that her Chancellor said
that those calling for frackings return
misunderstand the situation and that no
amount of shale gas would be enough to
lower the European price anytime soon so
prime minister is the chancellor wrong
about that the flight Justin
foreign
we are pulling every lever to improve
our energy Supply in Britain whether
it's whether it's the North Sea and
opening up more opportunity there which
the opposition front Venture against
whether it's fracking whether it's more
Renewables which I'm very supportive of
whether it's more solar panels in the
right place whether it's more nuclear
power stations which are opposed by the
SMP we are doing everything we can
because we can never be in a situation
again where we are dependent on
authoritarian regimes for our energy
thank you Mr Speaker over the past week
serious safeguarding failures by the
children's charity mermaids have come to
Light Revelations the charity said
breast flattening devices to Young Girls
behind their parents back promoted
harmful medical and surgical procedures
to Children hired a trustee with links
to pedophile organizations and a digital
education sorry a digital engagement
manager who posted pornographic images
online including of himself dressed as a
school girl
for years despite whistleblowers raising
along mermaids have had unfettered
access to vulnerable children
does my voice honorable friend agree
that it has taken far too long for these
concerns to be taken seriously and does
she also agree that it is high time for
a police investigation into the
activities of mermaids
[Applause]
it's very important that under 18s are
able to develop their own
decision-making capabilities and not be
forced into any kind of activity and
what I would say on the subject of the
investigation she raises of course those
matters should be raised and should be
properly looked at
so we're all day thank you very much Mr
Speaker for my constituents in Richmond
Park and for communities across
Southwest London from Wimbledon to
elmbridge any expansion of Heathrow
would be disastrous a third Runway would
see over 6 million more tons of carbon
pumped into the atmosphere every year
and two million households affected by
increased noise levels last week the
transport secretary said she supported
Heathrow expansion the Prime Minister
has previously stated she would support
a fourth Runway so does the Prime
Minister stand by her previous comments
or will she rule out government support
for construction of a third Runway at
Heathrow
yeah
well I I absolutely agree with what the
transport secretary said in her comments
and what we need to do is make sure that
Industries like the air industry become
more environmentally friendly you know I
support the development of low carbon
low-carbon technology in those sectors
that's the way we will help grow the
economy but also serve the environment
Virginia Crosby
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker and I'm delighted
to hear the Prime Minister be such a
champion for nuclear and my question is
when will the mission and plan for Great
British nuclear be announced the market
needs the confidence to invest in
nuclear in new nuclear like Wilbur in my
constituency of rsmore to help us
achieve Net Zero for our energy security
and to get thousands of high quality
jobs
[Applause]
[Music]
well I can tell my honorable friend that
Great British nuclear will be set up
this year and it will be bringing
forward new nuclear projects I'm
delighted about her support for wilfer
and to make sure that we have nuclear
power provided in Wales I'd just like to
see it right across the United Kingdom
too that Western thank you Mr Speaker
may I welcome her to her place
um I'm not sure how you measure a good
honeymoon Mr Speaker
after five weeks of a crisis conceived
in Downing Street of crashing pensions
interest rates Rising mortgage Market
turmoil and compete Financial chaos the
country has been left wanting divorce in
two recent polls 60 of this country
wants an immediate general election
the Prime Minister claims she's in this
Emoji will she give way to the public
yeah
Mr Speaker I think the last thing we
need is a general election
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that that concludes prime minister's
questions
let the people leave
[Applause]
[Music]
well that was promises questions the
Prime Minister making a speedy exit uh
let's bring in Beth review of political
editors here in the studio with me
um it's only the second prime minister's
questions that we've seen her do it's
been a really tumultuous few weeks she
had quite a lot to achieve there did she
achieve it
I don't think that was an easy prime
minister's questions for Liz trust but
given what's happened to her in her
first five weeks of Premiership you
wouldn't really be surprised by that I
think for kirstarma there were two
messages he wanted to get across there
uh will you reverse your mini budget
talking about how mortgages are going up
he's saying 500 pounds mortgages are
going up by and then talking about the
fact that Liz truss in his view was cut
in taxes for big corporations he noted
that corporation tax cut again he
noticed stamp Duty cuts for landlords
and he noted that there were not
increased taxes on people that get their
incomes from dividends and shares
raising all of these and saying again
why are you not on the side of working
people two clear attack lines for labor
there
on the mini budgets because as some
conservative back Ventures are saying as
well
labor think that some of these methods
will have to be reversed that they are
just not sustainable in terms of how the
markets have reacted in the state of the
public finances and then I think there
was another crucial part of that prime
minister's questions which I think is
one to bookmark and remember and that
was when the Prime Minister was asked by
kirstarma if she would stick to a pledge
major in the Tory leadership contest she
would not reduce public spending and she
said absolutely we are spending almost a
trillion pounds on public spending we're
spending we were spending 700 billion
back in 2010 what we will make sure is
that over the medium term debt is
falling but we will do that not by
cutting public spending but by making
sure we spend public money well and the
reason that matters Jane
obviously is because what
independent economists and forecasters
are saying is that there is a massive
black hole in the public finances and
that's been driven by unfunded tax cuts
denounced in the mini budget compounded
uh by the cost of government borrowing
going up because of the market reaction
that's created a black hole in the
public finances and The Institute of
physical studies yesterday was saying
that's to the tune of 60 billion pounds
so either some of the tax cuts will have
to be reversed or there will be spending
cuts to try and get the economy out of
that black hole and and that matters
because in the longer run that's what
investors invest in the UK on the back
of they want a fiscal plan they want
certainty that debt will be falling as a
percentage of GDP or that debt will be
or there is a plan to repay debt so I
think the Prime Minister there saying
there will be no spending cut so we're
not planning spending cards immediately
the back benches will sit there quietly
and say that is a not a sustainable
position and I think there could be some
Fallout of that in the coming days and
also we saw Liz truss also pushing back
on kirstama saying that that you know
asking him whether labor supports the
energy price guarantee uh and labor you
know that's one thing that labor haven't
been able to say that they would support
or not so and you sort of feel that
that's going to be her comeback exactly
Jane and if you thought kind of where
was kirstarma trying to play to in terms
of his attack lines
what Liz trust believes in many in her
cabinet believe is that the huge support
package that they announced for people
to deal with energy bills remember their
cap in wholesale prices they say that
that will mean that a typical household
won't pay more than two and a half
thousand pounds in energy bills it will
Flex depend on how much you lose another
straight cap but it certainly brings
bills down for people
Liz Tross feels that this is part of her
program which was huge support public
support for taxpayers and for families
that has kind of got lost in the midst
of the Ferrari around the top rate of
tax and the market reaction to the
budget so what she was doing there was
every time kirstarma attacked her she
was saying well look I have guaranteed
support for two years you've guaranteed
a package for six months and she's
really trying to get on the front foot
and and publicize what is a very retail
policy to voters I think the issue is is
in the tumultuous nature of what
happened after that mini budget that
package has been somewhat lost and what
people are looking at now is interest
rates going up mortgages going up uh
concerns about government borrowing
rates going up insecurity about Pension
funds with the bank of England having to
do those emergency bailouts and anger
quite frankly over that 45 top rate of
tax which now has been reversed so the
one good bit of her program is she would
see it has got completely lost in the
melee of everything else that has
happened with the government sheets
trying to get on the front foot I think
there's a question about whether or not
voters are listening the polls are just
dreadful for the conservatives at the
moment and Jane when I speak to former
cabinet ministers and Senior back
benchers behind the scenes lots of them
might not be publicly speaking out but
the mood is terrible and just at
conference with a group of MPS and and
you know former ministers saying they
don't think it's sustainable that she
can remain in office to the next
Revelation that discussion is still
going on behind the scenes amongst MPS
that they think maybe they will have to
try to change the leader whether that
happens what that looks like if it's
even possible they're all unknowns but
for promo Minister five weeks in for
your back benches to be actively having
those conversations is a reflection on
just how bad it's got in such a short
space of time for her she left the house
she said the last thing we need is the
general election herself uh Bev thanks
so much that's really interesting well
that's the view of our political editor
let's now go across the country to find
out what people outside of Westminster
think about what they have been hearing
from the Prime Minister this afternoon
how they think it may affect them well
let's uh speak to from South End on sea
at mortgage broker and director of R3
mortgages Riz Malik director at
Birmingham base Bakery lils par Lucy
Scott and also from Bradford on Avon and
wheelchair the president of the National
pensioners Convention Rosie McGregor
thank you all so much for joining us and
Riz Malik mortgage broker let's talk to
you first of all of course we've been
talking a lot about the economy this
morning uh the pound falling how over
the last few months how the last few
days been for you
I feel like I'm living in a dream and
someone's going to wake me up at some
moment in time and tell me that this was
all a joke or something the last few
months in the mortgage Market have been
very unstable but the last few weeks
have been a complete and utter Nightmare
and the problem that we have is that I
can't see the what's going to be done to
get us out of this mess okay we've got
mortgage rates that are changing on an
hourly basis we've got lenders repricing
their deals because the deals they're
coming out with a few hours later don't
make any economic sense but what really
irritates me is we have got a prime
minister who on your show and repeatedly
keeps on saying that interest rates are
not nothing to do with her and they're
set by the bank of England although
that's correct if you don't know as the
Prime Minister that the financial
markets hang on every word that you say
about the economic Outlook you shouldn't
be in the job this is a level economics
it's all the circle and the problem that
we have and the perfect storm that is
brewing is they're brought forward the
obr report to Halloween uh ironically uh
but then even if that has been delivered
and it's got a massive cherry on top and
the markets love it there isn't time to
digest that to reflect that into
mortgage pricing by the time the NPC
meet the following week and they're more
than likely going to raise interest
rates further so I just I I'm in utter
shock with what's happening at the
moment and in addition last week we had
a meeting and last week we had a meeting
of the chancellor and members of the
financial Community to come up with a
package well where is that package we
need speed in this situation at the same
rate as we had during covid otherwise I
fear for what's going to happen Okay
well that's pretty clear uh let's bring
in Lucy Scott from from Lil's parlor
Bakery Lucy just explained to us very
briefly how your organization works
first of all
so Lil's parlor is a cic so that's a
community interest company that means
we're a company registered for the
social good so our profits go back into
making sure that the community is kind
of helped so that's what I do so I buy
everything in in the same way as a
normal business don't receive any
discounts don't receive any help but
what happens is any profits that I make
go back directly into making sure that
we feed people basically and you you
basically it's a pay what you can so if
people come in and they can't afford to
pay for a loaf of bread you will
essentially give it to them
so there is a recommended donation
um so people can choose to pay the
recommended donation or they can pay
less they can pay a little bit more to
pay it forward but all our transactions
are completely Anonymous so people can
come here into a safe non-judgmental
space and be able to provide for their
family if that's what they need to do
okay so what's your Reflections on on
the world of politics over the last few
weeks and how people who are using your
services are coping
I you know just listening to the
gentleman before when he said I feel
like I'm just gonna one day somebody's
gonna be like Lucy Lucy it's all alright
it was all a big joke sort of thing
um the mood of my customers coming in is
just a lot of sadness to be honest the
people that come here they're working
people some of them have two or three
jobs and there's just no thought for how
normal people are gonna survive this how
much stress it's putting on them and
their families how it's affecting their
mental health so I wish that these
people from the government would go and
walk Round Aldi on a Monday afternoon go
and see how people are choosing between
a can of beans and a you know a packet
of pasta
it's fair enough standing there talking
about numbers and
they need to really start thinking about
how this is affecting normal people
because I do worry we've got a
generation of children coming up that
have seen nothing but their parents
worry now for two three four years how
is that going to reflect in the future
and how are people on the ground now
gonna cope you know it's affecting
everybody badly and I don't think
there's enough compassion
understanding that that's actually the
case on the ground
okay Rosie McGregor from the National
pensioners Convention
um Rosie obviously we've been talking a
lot about the economy and there's been a
lot of talk about the impact on pensions
pensions are one of those subjects that
some people understand a great deal
about I'm sure you're one of them most
people don't really understand a great
deal and most people probably don't even
understand if they have a pension where
the money goes how it's looked after who
who are the ones in your understanding
the ones on the defined benefit pensions
that potentially could be affected How
concerned are you about the economic
potential impact on on those people
very concerned there's a massive concern
amongst many pensioners following the
mini budget and the impact it's having
on the stock market and those on defined
benefits
um potentially depending on where the
Investments are made could find that
they are at some risk and certainly
those who are not yet retired but
looking forward to retirement will be
very very worried now I'm fairly lucky
myself in that I was on a final salary
pension from local government but even
so I am extremely worried at the present
time by inflation and I just don't feel
that Liz truss and her government
actually get it I mean she says she said
in pmqs I'm listening but quite frankly
I don't think she's listening to
pensioners and um
even the bank of England and the IMF are
saying basically she doesn't get it so
when is she going to get it and we need
uh I think a general election
um because we can't go on like this and
many pensioners tell me they are facing
a really Bleak choice between putting
food on the table heating their homes
traveling anywhere and many feel a sense
of loneliness and despair and I have to
say as well some of those pensioners
would be Tory voters well indeed and
you've heard primus's questions raise
Malik in terms of what you heard today
from the Prime Minister we had a talking
about no fault evictions
um and and whether or not they will be
banned you obviously have a lot of buy
to let landlords on on your books what
what do you think the impact on those
kind of policies is going to have
to buy to let Market is one of the
markets on the most concerned about the
problem that you're going to have is
people are going to be coming off deals
and the way lenders calculate the loan
amounts they're not going to be able to
borrow the same amount of money and any
raises in the actual rates are going to
be passed on to the tenants and it's
just going to be a cycle because those
tenants are are by our first time buyers
of tomorrow so it's going to take them
longer to save up for a property they're
not going to be able to so they're then
going to call on the bank of mum and dad
to dip into their pocket to help them
onto the housing ladder this is just
going to have knock-on effects from one
stage to the other because landlords are
going to look at their numbers and say
this doesn't make any sense anymore and
although the landlord gets beaten up uh
regularly in the UK the landlord solves
a very very uh key problem that we have
in the private rental sector uh and the
government's not there with a solution
to house the people that the landlords
are actually assisting so I I'm fearful
for that market even more than I am for
the residential Market
okay
um Lucy in terms of of how you're
managing on a daily basis the cost of
the stuff you're buying it's fluctuating
a lot at the moment is it isn't it I
understand you're not even taking a
salary I mean how how sustainable is it
that you can keep going with your
business
I'm really lucky
um we don't have any children we
actually do live in a rented property
and we've got we've got a good landlord
um but my husband at the moment is the
person that's providing our kind of you
know basic or stuff at home so I'm in a
lucky position to do that ingredients
costs are insane just last week the
price of 12 eggs went up 40 from Monday
to Friday why there's just
it's just every week so even basic
ingredients like butter chocolate flour
simple things that would have you know
have been considered cheap store covered
ingredients and now becoming
unobtainable for some people and I just
don't understand how this is going to
ever end it's just a spiral that seems
to be out of control and at some point
people have got to say this we've had
enough of this it's got to stop
otherwise the society as we know it at
the moment I believe is just going to
collapse but long term I'm here I'm
doing what I do I have amazing
supportive customers I will keep being
here for as long as I can I'm very very
stubborn I will always speak up for
people and for as long as I can do that
I'm I'm sticking around
bless you for that Lucy Rosie said that
she thought a general election was
needed do you think that would solve
anything
I I find it really I would love a
general election
um I think that there's a lot of stuff
that needs to be weeded out however I'm
not sure that there's strong leadership
on any
anywhere at the moment I just think it
all needs a big shake-up and
it just needs a little bit of a fresh
start to be honest some new voices some
some new ideas some I think we just need
General change across our whole
political system at the moment okay back
to Rosie you know aside from a general
election which the Prime Minister has
just said in prime minister's questions
that nobody needs what what else could
the government do do you think to to
help restore confidence in the pension
market and help restore confidence of
pensioners and indeed those approaching
their position age
I think there is a tremendous worry
there amongst pensioners and I think the
government could do something with
regard to for example the triple lock on
the state pension now Liz truss did
promise that she would restore the
triple lock for next year but there have
been voices saying that this will not
happen and it is really important that
the triple lock on the state pension
which ensures that it will be going up
and in line with inflation is really
important and a lot of people tell me
that uh oh well pensioners are quite
well off can I tell you that the
majority of pensioners are not well off
and the majority of pensioners rely on
the state pension so the triple lock is
important to us and I think really she
should just ditch her policies on
uh money and what has been happening uh
so that we can actually
um
go back to a more stable economy and I
think this is the the worst problem with
the lot is we are in such a state of
instability at the present time that no
one knows what the future will hold and
that is a particular worry for
pensioners okay we've only got 20
seconds but I just want to bring in
rears be again very briefly is because
both of of Lucy and Rosie said that they
would like to see another general
election yes I know would you like to
see that do you think it would solve
anything
I don't think it's going to solve
anything I think the markets will react
badly to it but I do think that the
position of the chancellor needs to be
re-advertised okay not a general
election just a new Chancellor uh
rismatic mortgage broker Lucy Scott from
Lil's parlor and Ross McGregor from the
National pensioners Convention thank you
all so much really great to talk to you
and get your thoughts today thank you
you're watching Sky News lots more
coming up after this short break
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello good afternoon you're watching Sky
News at one this trust insists she will
not cut spending to balance the books
while Kristen armor accuses the prime
minister of ducking her responsibilities
what we will make sure is that over the
medium term the debt is falling but we
will do that not by cutting public
spending but by making sure we spend
public money well
when will she stop ducking
responsibility do the right thing and
reverse her Kamikaze budget which is
causing so much pain
growth shrinks the pound Falls fresh
economic fears amid Rising concern about
the state of the UK economy
pensions back in Peril the bank of
England Sparks fresh concern as the
governor rules out extending a support
lifeline
Vladimir Putin ready to connect the gas
or reconnect it even the Russian
president says Moscow will resume
supplies to Europe
[Music]
thank you
and remembering one of the last Golden
Age Hollywood stars tributes to Murder
She Wrote Legends Dame Angela Lansbury
after her death at the age of 96.
[Music]
hello good afternoon welcome to Sky News
at 1 the return of prime minister's
questions this lunchtime has seen a
blistering exchange of words over the
economy accompanied by shouts and jeers
in the Commons this trust insisted she
would not cut public spending to balance
the books okay starmer accused the prime
minister of ducking her responsibilities
we are seeing interest rates Rising
globally we are doing they are
calling war in Ukraine and what we are
doing is helping people with lower stamp
Duty helping people with their energy
costs reducing inflation with our energy
package and keeping taxes low and I
notice that the honorable gentleman had
a damask in conversion last night when
he backed our cut to National Insurance
Mr Speaker The Economist in turmoil
people are really worried this is really
not the time to descend into absolutely
nonsense attacks about last night
there's no point there's no point
there's no point trying to hide it
everyone can see what has happened the
Taurus went on a borrowing spree sending
mortgage rates through the roof they are
skyrocketing by 500 pounds a month and
for nearly 2 million homeowners their
fixed rate deals are coming to an end
next year they're worried sick and
everybody in this house knows it they
won't forgive they won't forget and nor
should they when will she stop ducking
responsibility do the right thing and
reverse her Kamikaze budget which is
causing so much pain we are spending
almost a trillion pounds of public
spending we were spending
700 billion back in 2010. what we will
make sure is that over the medium term
the debt is falling but we will do that
not by cutting public spending but by
making sure we spend public money well
and the honorable talks
ending which he doesn't seem to
the tea but the reality can't criticize
us on one hand for spending money on the
other hand claiming we're cutting public
expenditure
they can cheer I hope they listen very
very carefully to that last answer
because other people have listened very
very carefully to it
who voted for this
who voted for this who voted for this
not homeowners paying an extra 500 extra
on their mortgages who voted this not
working people paying for tax cuts to
the largest companies who voted for this
not even most of the MPS behind her who
know who know you can't pay for tax cuts
on the never never does she think does
she think the public will ever forgive
the conservative party if they keep on
defending this madness and go ahead with
our Kamikaze budget
Mr Speaker what our budget has delivered
is security for
the next
two it's made sure that we're going to
see higher economic growth lower
inflation and more opportunities the way
that we will get our country growing is
through more jobs more growth more
opportunities not through higher taxes
higher spending and his friends in the
union stopping hard-working people get
to work
well our political editor Beth Rigby is
here and Beth has been a bit of a Hiatus
and prime minister's questions because
of death of the queen and the party
conferences are we now sort of getting a
flavor of of how the the back and forth
Works between the Prime Minister and
kirst armor the kind of themes that
they're going to be attacking each other
on
yeah we're getting a sense of it in
terms of it was always quite a sort of
Personality based contest if you like
between Johnson and starma but between
trust and stamina what you're getting is
the questions around policy and economic
policy and it's unsurprising given that
mini budget that was a maxi budget
that's reset uh the economic direction
of the country and that is a prime
minister stand in the dispatch spots
today who is still dealing with the
Fallout of it and questions over it
about how the numbers do or don't add up
and for Kia stalma this is really Fart
whole territory because it ties into the
market nervousness it ties into voter
anxiety and it plays into the fact that
Liz truss is struggling with her own
back benches about the policies she has
announced and actually I think what you
saw in that prime minister's questions
was two things from
one where you reverse the tax cuts and
two were you guaranteed that there won't
be public spending cuts given that as a
result of the policies announced those
unfunded tax cuts coupled with the way
in which the markets reacted which made
the cost of government borrowing go up
the reason that matters Jane is 25 of
government borrowing is index linked so
it moves with the market so if the
markets don't like it much and the cost
of borrowing goes up that is a direct
cost to the taxpayer because it goes on
to government debt so she answered in
terms of spending cuts that she's
committed to public spending as it
stands that will raise questions about
how that's uh sustainable and and she's
not planning to reverse the tax cuts and
actually I should say in the Commons in
the past few minutes another
conservative has broken ranks with the
government on this is this is the
treasury chair man chair of the treasury
selection committee Mel stride he has
said that there should be rowing back on
tax announcements to help reassure the
markets that's what he's asked for the
chief secretary Chris philp has replied
there are not any plans to reverse any
of the tax measured announced in the
growth plan I think what you've got
really is a prime minister that has
announced a policy that has had a huge
backlash politically and economically
and that is what is going uh to set the
weather and determine what happens at
Prime Minister's questions in the coming
weeks I mean I only hear second pmqs but
but already calls for another general
election yeah that's it I think this is
the last question let's have a listen to
that one
in two recent polls 60 of this country
wants an immediate general election the
Prime Minister claims she's in listening
mode will she give way to the public
yeah
Mr Speaker I think the last thing we
need is a general election
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you can hear the Jews from the labor
back benches there because their
argument is the last thing you need to
lose trust is a general election given
that the conservatives are now between
20 and 30 points or more behind in the
polls depending on which one you look at
look for interesting our people's panel
that we just had two of the three said
they would quite like a general election
and one said don't a general election
just want a new Chancellor well I think
the thing as well is from a Liz trust
perspective or a quasi-quartile
perspective what they've done is they've
put this plan in place and they've
turbocharged the beginning of the tax
cuts which has caused all the
controversy but the reason they're
trying to do that is they are convinced
that they can get enough economic growth
to grow tax revenues and grow the
economy so that when they have an
election and it needs to be held at the
very latest by January 2024 that the
economy is growing people see the
results of their policies and they think
the public will look more favorably on
them I have to say Jane when you talk to
conservative MPS behind the scenes they
are looking at this a relationship
between the Prime Minister and back
branch is always transactional they are
there this this is their job they are
now looking at the prospect of
potentially losing their seats at the
next general election if Liz trust
cannot close this Gap in the polls and
there's a lots of discussion even after
five weeks have been in office for her
just five weeks about whether or not
they should let her be the one that
leads them into a general election the
party is very split on this different
people I speak to give me different
points of view but the fact that that is
even being discuss so soon after
replacing Boris Johnson gives you a
sense of the turmoil she's in she's
going to go to talked about benches at
the 1922 backbench committee uh this
afternoon she's also now hosting uh
drinks parties and events with MPS in an
effort to sort of Love bomb them and win
them over but I wonder whether for some
of them it will now fall on deaf ears
and the damage is already done that's
the big question it's extraordinary
times better thanks very much
well in terms of the economy that
unexpectedly shrank in August the value
of the pound falling once again
overnight amid Rising concern about the
health of the country's finances the
bank of England partially sparked new
fears after the governor doubled down
and ruled out an extension to the
pension's lifeline that he introduced in
a bid to calm the crisis in the markets
well the GDP shrank by 0.3 percent in
August compared to July Which is far
worse than expected the growth in July
has also been revised downwards from 0.2
to 0.1 percent and figures that are far
short of the 2.5 percent rate of growth
the chancellor says he wants to achieve
will overnight the value of the pound
fell following those comments from the
bank of England about the imminent
expiry of its intervention
well the bank's intervention showed
things up when it first decided to take
action so let's look at what's been
happening with pensions over the last
few weeks well some Pension funds were
put at risk following a huge sell-off in
government bonds known as guilds in the
wake of the Chancellor's mini budget
announcement on the 23rd of September
buying a Government Bond or a guild is
effectively lending money to the
government to raise funds for its
spending initiatives
well the tax cutting plans announced in
the mini budget the biggest package of
tax cuts and generations caused unease
amongst investors and this is because as
borrowing increases investors lose
confidence in the government being able
to pay back the money lent to them and
this triggered a sell-off in guilts and
caused their value to plummet which in
turn caused yields to soar well this
sell-off risked a liquidity crisis for
final salary pension schemes which
typically own many guilts and so are
more exposed to the shifts in prices
in a very significant 65 billion pound
move the bank of England stepped in to
buy bonds which gave support for pension
schemes and reduced the instability and
that move prevented some final salary
schemes falling too far
in the past few days however the
situation has been returning to where it
was previously the yields on the bonds
of risen the pound has fallen almost
back to where they were before the bank
of England's intervention a fortnight
ago
at the bank of England's Governor Andrew
Bailey has ruled out extending its Bond
buying support past Friday's deadline
but this morning the financial times has
reported that the bank has been
privately briefing Market participants
that it might extend it after all or
joined Now by our business presenter Ian
King in the city I mean what are the
chances that we think that the um
that they may well extend this after all
the bank seemed pretty straightforward
when Andrew belly said that they weren't
going to extend it
yes that's right Andrew Bailey uh quite
clear last night he said to the Pension
funds you've got three days left now she
says the financial times reported in the
early hours of this morning that
privately the bank has been guiding some
Market participants that they might
continue their emergency guilt purchases
Beyond this Friday but then the bank
doubled down it issued a statement this
morning in which it said uh it's been
made absolutely clear to Market
participants chiefly the banks that sit
on the other side of these derivatives
trades with the Pension funds that the
scheme is going to end on Friday but
paradoxically of course by saying this
the bank has really made it absolutely
clear to Pension funds that they've got
between now and Friday to get their
houses in order to raise the cash that
they need to uh to uh raise to meet the
collateral requirements of the banks on
the other sides of the trades that they
have been doing and effectively that's
led to another wave of selling today and
you've seen that uh transpiring in the
guilt Market I think I can show you the
30-year Guild which is the uh the long
guilt that's one of the main Assets in
which I'm sorry we don't have that chain
anyway you'll have to take my word for
it I can tell you that the yield on
30-year guilts has gone to uh north of
five percent 5.074 was the last I
checked which is as you said earlier
more or less back to where it was when
the backstage that dramatic intervention
first in the guilt Market a fortnight
ago today meanwhile the 20-year yield
well that's gone to 4.1 5.141 and that
is the highest since September 2008 so
you're seeing multi-year highs being hit
in these uh guilt yields and it's really
I can't stress it enough these are
really unprecedented moves obviously uh
goat yields have been pretty depressed
over recent years with ultra low
interest rates those those moves have
really uh reversed in a matter of months
in some unprecedented movements in Guild
Hills and that is why you've seen this
big spike now it's worth pointing out
that the bank also today uh in its
statement pointed out that there are
still other measures that it's got under
a way to try and help Pension funds out
there's a repo facility as it's known in
the jargon which will remain which will
exist beyond the 14th of October but
it's quite likely I think that you are
going to see a bit more selling over the
next 48 hours or so just in case uh Mr
Bailey and the bank are not bluffing and
that really will be it in terms of
giving Pension funds time to sort
themselves out
okay Ian thanks very much
now Vladimir Putin says Moscow is ready
to resume gas supplies to Europe by the
nordstream 2 pipeline the Russian
president once again accused the U.S of
sabotaging Nordstrom one and two causing
a massive gas leak and taking them out
of service
foreign
should be decided together by Russia and
our partners in the European Union
countries I'll say that restoring the
streams that have been damaged in the
Baltic Sea is of course possible but it
will only make sense if there is a
future economically and of course with
ensured security of the route they are
the primary conditions we with the
Europeans will come to a mutual solution
to supply gas through the surviving
branch
Russia is ready the ball is as we say on
the eu's court if they want then they
can just open the tap and that's all
Brussels by a Europe correspondent Adam
Parsons who makes it sound so simple
doesn't he
he does uh I mean worth saying that
North stream 2 has never functioned it
was never opened never turned on so the
idea that it is a simple matter of
turning a tap seems uh a little unlikely
but I don't think Vladimir Putin
honestly believes that there is any
chance whatsoever that this offer will
be taken up he's not really talking to
European leaders here I think he's
talking to two constituencies one is the
people of Europe he is saying to them
look you are in for what he described as
being the sort of winter you'd have in
the Middle Ages when he said people
going around collecting wood to keep
themselves warm now I don't suppose
Europe really thinks it's heading
towards that but he is trying to say to
European civilians this is down to your
government it's down to European leaders
that you are facing these Sky High
Energy costs it's not my fault rusher
will supply energy if you want it
complain to your leaders don't moan to
me the other constituency he's talking
to is frankly the world outside Europe
uh there is a pretty concerted
opposition to Vladimir Putin to his
invasion of Europe invasion of Ukraine
around the continent of Europe and
indeed around sort of NATO members but
around the rest of the world in China
India and Pakistan and and Beyond
there's a lot more Equanimity in China
particularly in India have offered if
not support then not opposition to
Vladimir Putin going to be interesting
at the same time as this is all
happening there is a debate going on at
the United Nations debate of censure
into Russia can be very very interesting
to see who supports him and who doesn't
I think Vladimir Putin in his mind
thinks I can sort of do without Europe
what I need is the backing of the at
least some of the rest of the world
and Adam NATO of course G7 leaders are
meeting in Brussels today the defense
ministers for NATO as well meeting we
spoke to General Sir Richard Sheriff a
couple of hours ago this guy and he said
he was very concerned that actually when
it comes to the the countries who are
contributing towards the war in Ukraine
that that many of those countries
cupboards are starting to become bare
that is going to be a concern today
isn't it
that is one of the main things that Jen
stoltenberg will be telling NATO defense
ministers as they meet here in Brussels
is that resources are have been finite
and that they are running low uh and
that this isn't just about military
intervention it is about industrial
might as well he will be telling all of
these NATO uh countries that they need
to now look into production about making
weapons the other thing that he will be
talking about is the requirement to
supply air defense systems to Ukraine
obviously in recent times we have seen
how Russia has stepped up its use of
missiles Ukraine has asked for air
defense systems it is getting some from
the United States from Germany from a
promise of France and Italy it has asked
for more from NATO from the United
Kingdom from more backing from the
European Union and that is something
that I think Jen stoltenberg uh will
Echo I mean we are reaching some kind of
inflection point around this combination
military and energy pressure we're
saying also Jane that today there is
another pipeline that is in Peru in
Poland the Pern oil pipeline that runs
out of Russia there's a problem on that
pipeline at the moment there is no
suggestion that that is sabotage but uh
going back to the north stream where we
started from NATO blames Russia for
sabotaging that Russia blames the United
States or at least NATO powers for
sabotaging it and nobody really knows
what happened this is once again this
field of hybrid Warfare about diplomacy
military attacks on infrastructure
potential cyber attacks that fog of war
that Vladimir Putin has always proved
himself to be an exponent of
Adam Parsons thanks very much
now of course has heard how a nurse on
trial accused of murdering seven babies
and attempting to murder 10 more sent a
sympathy card to The Grieving family of
one of the children involved jurors have
today heard that Lucy letby apparently
tried to kill one baby girl who weighed
just over two pounds at Birth four times
before finally succeeding Sky's Katarina
vitotsi is at Manchester Crown Court
Forest Katarina
yes that's baby girl referred to uh in
the court hearing this morning is child
eye baby girl born 27 weeks premature
now the prosecution say as you alluded
to that Lucy letby attempted to kill
this baby girl four times before
succeeding those attempts made between
September and October 2015 and in each
case the prosecution say that 32 year
old neonatal nurse deliberately injected
air into the baby's stomach which caused
the child's lungs to collapse and
eventually leading to her faithful
collapse Nick Johnson Casey said child's
eye was born very early and very small
but she was doing well by the time Lucy
letby got her hands on her what happened
to child I followed the pattern of what
had happened to others before and what
was yet to happen to others all of a
sudden out of nowhere came vomiting
breathing problems and critical
desaturations and then going on to
describe Lucy letby's for alleged
attacks it was persistent calculators
and cold-blooded Nick Johnson Casey also
then went on to describe the case that
they believe of child came a baby girl
in February 2016 Born Again prematurely
and at this point they described a
doctor a pediatric consultant on the
neonate award starting to feel
uncomfortable with what he perceives as
a coincidences between children
catastrophically collapsing and Lucy
letby's present so at that point in
February 2016 the doctor entered the
room where he could see a baby being
left alone with Lucy letby and the
prosecution continued again that as he
the doctor walked into room one he saw
Lucy letby standing over child care is
incubator she did not have her hand
inside the incubator but he could see
from the monitor the child K's oxygen
saturation level was falling dangerously
however the alarm was not sounding as it
should have been Lucy letby had not
called for help and was making no
efforts to help child K now the
prosecution argued that this is a
feature of this case that Lucy letpy was
deliberately turning off alarm monitors
that she was falsifying notes and in
several cases uh cons contacting or
searching for the families of the
deceased children or the sick children
on Facebook and also as we heard in that
case of child eye sending a sympathy
card she had said admitted in earlier
police interview that that was not
normal but she said she had got
unusually close to the family of child's
eye the prosecution say that this
actually just exhibits an ongoing
unusual in interests that she had in
these families and their children a
brief of German here for lunch
prosecution opening statement expected
to continue from two o'clock
thank you very much
this is Sky News at one coming up
[Music]